hey kkk are you a fan of cultural
appropriation
of course i can't go down to the local
supermarket unless i'm dressed like a
mexican bandit or as i like to think
about it your cousin
in that case you're going to love beer
rebel noodles
they make award-winning delicious ramen
noodles with an irish twist
for bankruptcy and alcoholism no all
their noodles are homemade using
high quality ingredients in fact
respected food critic jay raynor
called them deserving of poetry what a
cuck man up jay
their sauces noodles and broths are
created using skills
that were developed over years of
working in michelin-starred kitchens
they're dead easy to make the noodles
take one minute to cook
and the whole dish takes only 10 minutes
to put together
in the comfort of your own home i'm
hungry just explaining this to you
you're always hungry mate i mean that's
a fair point go to beerble.com that's
dot com b-i-a-r-e-b-e-l-dot-com get a
tasty flavor of the east in your dinner
time
when you change regulations you're
benefiting one group over another and to
go back to your inequality point what's
happened is the corruption of politics
has essentially meant that it's all gone
to a tiny sliver of humanity
and the rest of us have been living on
crumbs
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster
i'm constantine kitchen and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people
our brilliant guest today is a political
economist at brown university in america
and a returning guest to trigonometry
mark blythe welcome back
it's lovely to be back it's also nice to
be thought off as what was that
fascinating
was that a fabulous guest absolutely
well you were always good to be
fascinating
you are and we know that you will be
again but last time we had a brilliant
conversation
uh it was about a year ago and if you
remember we were talking about the fact
that one lockdown
is probably affordable two or three a
lot more difficult
uh how do you assess the year that we've
had since
well i don't know how many martinis
you've had involuntarily
over the past year but i'd say my
pandemic drinking reached olympic
levels and you know had to be dialed
back so that was the main personal cost
um is that scottish levels mark
well i was just getting up to scottish
levels you know so
let's keep it real all right the serious
point on this
you know one of the funniest things that
happened is the
we always read these events through our
political biases
right and this is particularly true even
of vaccines right you'd think
putting anti-hardcore anti-vaxxers to
one side you would think
that would be something that would be
kind of beyond politics whatever but
it's not right
so the lockdowns of course become a
classic example of this
at the start of the pandemic during the
first wave there was a common meme that
went around which i actually enjoyed and
shared in which was the following
hey it turns out that if you're a big
country run by a big loudmouth male
[ __ ] you're not doing too well and if
you're a small country run by a woman
that shuts up and just gets [ __ ] done
you're doing pretty well isn't that
funny and that kind of worked for a
while but then it got more complex and
it turned out that some of those small
countries were just as screwed as
everybody else and then some of the big
ones kind of got a little better on it
i don't know if i did this after you we
talked but um
i did a couple of things online and a
spanish filmmaker approached me
and put together a movie which you can
look at on youtube called the mustang in
the volvo
which basically describes the different
behavior of the american economy
vis-a-vis the european economies
and when you get right to the end of
this one another fascinating one came up
which was
now we've got the vaccines let's see
what happens
so of course particularly united states
but you see this across western europe
as well
there's the concern with getting the
elderly the vulnerable minorities etc
right
but there's a problem in doing so these
are the people that usually don't trust
the state
want to hide from the state and have
every reason every now and again to
actually quite rightly fear this state
they haven't had too many pleasant
interactions with them
so there was all this attention
particularly in the blue states in the
us and like finding the most vulnerable
in the minorities and equity and all
that sort of stuff
and it meant we were absolutely stuffing
it meanwhile down in florida where this
didn't give a [ __ ] it was like let's
open up a stadium and if you've got an
arm we'll just whack something into you
and they started to do really well
so i think what this whole thing has
shown is that it really up ends
and really exposes how anything can be
read through your own political biases
right there's no truth about the
pandemic apart from the one that we put
on it and that is a partisan game for
better or worse
and it's interesting that you say that
that literally everything
has been politicized because that's what
we see here in the uk
how has that affected politics do you
think that was a significant fact on
what happened with trump and biden etc
i think it was in the you know one way
to think about biden and i don't think
this has changed is like everybody just
needed two years of quiet
right but really it was just like you
enough of the tweet the tweet storm at
two in the morning wondering if the
missiles are flying right
so uncle joe was just like can we just
have some calm time that would be nice
right and the way that he's handled this
is very much along those lines
you'll notice that uh for all the
attempt to politicize cancel culture
on the wall etc right that you get with
fox and the other media here and you see
also in the united kingdom
uh joe doesn't play that game because
you can bait your activists into having
those conversations because that's what
your activists care about
but basically if you don't respond then
it's a non-problem
so what's interesting about biden is he
wants to talk about the things he wants
to talk about and he refuses to talk
about anything else
which is a very interesting kind of
anti-political play
because you can't really lever that into
the stuff that you want as opposition
if he just won't talk about it so you
can go on about the walk crew the squad
all that
stuff he's just got nothing to say about
that so it just doesn't really stick
so he's got a very interesting way that
that's played playing in a sense and
we'll see how long that can handle
but you know but beneath it you just go
back to the handling of the pandemic
you know you still have i think the
latest poll was somewhere in the region
of about
40 republicans said that they're
definitely not getting it
and i mean a partisan divide on vaccines
just seems crazy if you think about it
but there it is
and you still have uh over 50
republicans
accepting the line that the election was
stolen i mean put that in the british
context for a minute
imagine if the conservative party just
said when labour won
not it was stolen and everybody went out
and had a look at it and you appointed
your commission and you had to look
through all the votes and you went no
actually it was totally fine they went
nope stolen that's it it's just stolen
right
you're poisoning the well that's
permanent politicalized politicization
and it's deeply undermining american
democracy
so on the one hand you've got biden
who's playing a good game of like i'm
not going to play that politics
but on the other hand you have an
opposition party which effectively says
[ __ ] democracy
and that's not cool it's not on the
other hand
i know a lot of people on the right who
would make the in my opinion very
legitimate counter argument which is
when donald trump got elected we got
russiagate which turns out to be a
nonsense right no completely no no i
totally buy that right
but there's a difference between that
and basically saying an election that
was fine
was stolen right that's actually
qualitatively different
so i just think this is like i think the
united states is very much an
inflection point basically what biden is
trying to do is chucking off money at
the problem that populism has abated
i'm not sure that's going to work and we
could talk about why and we could bring
that to britain and hartley pool
whatever you want to go
but well let's talk about the economy
mark let's talk about the economy
because
that's really the thing that is
fascinating to me
uh in terms of what has happened so we
we've obviously in the uk we've paid
everybody not to work for
god knows how long now that didn't quite
happen in america
but but nonetheless this is obviously
costing everything that's happening is
costing people
and governments and nations a huge
amount of money where are we
economically around the west
so the united states is i mean so here's
the thing
yes everybody's got more debt than when
they started but interest rates are at a
700 year low
right and what matters is the maturity
of your debt this is something you never
ever hear in the media what matters is
how much debt do you have coming up at a
certain point
and how long do you need how much more
do you need to ask you to effectively
keep that stable
and what's the interest rate you're
going to get that so there's a little
equation solvency equation you can use
to figure this stuff out
and if you run everybody's through his
numbers through it despite the huge rise
in debt
it's actually cheaper to pay stuff off i
mean the really the really
duh question at this point is if you
want to do you know infrastructure if
you want to do investment all that sort
of stuff
why not just issue an absolute ton of
30-year bonds just now
basically one percent because with one
percent inflation that's a zero interest
rate
which basically over 30 years eats
itself like why would you not do that
so you know there is no giant funding
crisis at this point in time and nor
does it look likely that there is going
to be one
so then the question is how big is the
rebound well the rebound is kind of
proportional to
how much slack there is in the economy
and how much pen up demand you have in
the economy
and i think what you're going to see is
two surprise not really surprises here
the america is going to come back with
very very strong growth over the next
two years possibly sustaining it above
four percent
uh and the united kingdom is going to
come back stronger than people think as
well
now the brexit stuff is going to weigh
on that if you actually look into the
trade stats you do begin to see this
effect
but it's not really that bad at least so
far
and more importantly when you consider
that you could be stuck in the european
union where once again the north is
about to screw the south and
nobody can really agree on anything and
the pandemic relief fund is actually too
small
to do any good even for italy etc etc
then the uk is actually in a better spot
so as it goes over the next couple of
years there will be a very very big
rebound which is exactly what people
around biden are hoping on
but mark surely you know we've got all
these people here on
furlough there's a number of you know of
of
companies that have gone to the wall
small businesses particularly in sectors
like
travel retail i mean
catering has gone bust surely that's
going to have a really serious effect on
our job mark and on our economy as a
whole
yeah but it depends on how much comes
back so i mean for example
i'm going to be going to the cotswolds
in august try going go
try getting a hotel in the cotswolds in
august
anywhere in the freaking cotswolds right
they're pretty book solid right
so certain sectors are definitely coming
back strong for me the really
interesting one and this is the big one
going forward is what happens with
commercial
estate so if you've got a i'll give you
two examples right if you're in the tech
industry tons of your
really important workers work from home
anyway techies and basements writing
code
troubleshooting all that sort of stuff
so there's nothing new there
but what has basically told google is we
don't need that giant campus
in palo alto we just don't right apple
doesn't need half the offices it's got
etc etc
so if you're in a tech firm or a firm
that can really be platform think sort
of like corporate human resources back
office to finance
boom they're not coming back on the
other hand you've got businesses like
finance think the city of london
where everything's about face-to-face
the ecosystem deal-making
co-presence is economists call it right
they're going back to the office
but a lot of commercial real estate is
going to be over the next couple of
years
so if you're looking for you know
fragility in the economy it's not the
fact that a few catering firms are going
to
have gone bust they will be picked up
again as things expand
for me the big one as well what happens
to all that real estate investment which
is super expensive
what happens to downtown right what
happens to the preta monge economy
if only half the people come back to the
office right that's where you really
begin to see structural change
and it also brings into question mark
what is going to be the future of cities
has covered rendered the city irrelevant
so it's funny i'm just talking to john
friedman who's an economist friend of
mine here at brown
and he had a great line on this which is
basically cities have been the growth
nodes and have pulled in people capital
and resources
from everywhere for the past 150 years
doesn't matter where you look
so are we actually saying that there'll
be a slight rebalancing against that in
certain sectors
probably or we're saying that the city's
days are numbered
that's a big bet that's a big bet right
so you know
it would take a lot to unwind london now
you know on the one hand
given the fact that if you look at gva
which is gross value added the
underlying component of gdp growth
the only bit of london that grows
according to the o of the uk that grows
according to the ons
is actually london and effectively the
rest of the country lives on transfers
now it would be nice to rebalance that
and they're you know
thinking about leveling up all the rest
of it is exactly the way to do that
but you know what nobody's sure how to
do that basically once a city loses its
industrial rationale
it's kind of hard for it to to reboot
its way back some places manage it
there's pittsburgh in the united states
which was the steel town which became
basically biotech university healthcare
right
but not everybody can play that trick so
take dundee where i'm from right
we were we have the unique honor of
being the first town in the world as far
as i'm aware to de-industrialize
because we were screwed by nylon right
we used to be the packaging uh plant for
the world
all the jute fibers would come from
india they'd boil them and turn them
into packaging in dundee and then they
would send them out to package
everything
nylon comes in you're done right so we
effectively started losing that industry
in the 1950s
has dundee come back right
it's got games video games it's got
biotech a little bit
it's got a few things but there's
nothing there when you think about
dundeen you go
that's what they do so the future for
those cities is actually much much more
uncertain than
a place like london essentially
dissolving right that's not going to
happen
ma and from the economic point of view
if you come back to the macro side of
things
there's a couple of things i want to ask
you about first of all
what did you make of the difference now
i understand the vulva and the mustang
metaphor which we talked about last time
the difference between america and the
uk
that's obviously very clear what did you
make of the decision
in the uk for example to have a furlough
two house self-employment grants to give
companies grants
and to support people through this
period do you think that was the right
decision or is the american model a
better one
well here's the weird thing about it
eventually the american model became
more like the british model
right so they they ended up extending
unemployment benefits even in places
like florida where they really didn't
want to do it
you had to be hardcore alabama
mississippi deep south
not to take the free money that was on
the table right and you know is there
such a thing as free money well at the
moment there is
because essentially you can borrow a
negative real rate which means somebody
out there in the world is so keen to
hold a bond
as a safe asset they're willing to lose
money on the transaction if they hold it
to duration
so in other words i borrowed 10 i
borrowed 10
from you and a year from now i give you
nine back i mean it's a no-brainer yeah
so on a 10-year bill on a 10-year bill
right if you've got like a negative real
rate and you're on it over 10 years you
get nine bucks back
that would be yeah exactly but you're
willing to do that because you're
betting essentially that that nine bucks
not only will be there
the economy that the bond is tied to
will be bigger so in a sense you'll get
more for your nine bucks right
so it's the safety play and if the whole
world's in safety play mode
it's dead easy to do that so you know
which one's better
the puzzle in the united states just now
is the is everybody just lying as we
used to call it in scotland on the brew
uh because they're finally getting
decent unemployment benefits and
nobody's going back to work well you
know if you actually look into the data
on this it's kind of weird it's like
some
sectors rather than others or whatever
but here's the thing
we've had chronic wage stagnation for
the bottom 40 to 60 percent
in the us for the past 30 years this is
a feature it's not a bug
right the design is we need to get wages
for the bottom 60 percent of people
up that's why they're so angry that's
why they're so pissed off
so the fact that there's a shortage in
certain sectors and employers are having
to pay more
that's the plan right that's not an
error that's exactly what they're aiming
for
well that was going to be my other
question to you because one and look
i think economically i'm probably in the
center maybe even eileen wright on
economics i would argue
but when i look at something like
inequality to me that's a huge issue
and one of the things that has happened
during the course of the pandemic is
i don't know whether it's a transfer of
wealth and income
uh you tell me or is it just the
accumulation of wealth and income
right at the top by the people who
already had everything while everybody
else essentially forced
to live off handouts uh what has been
the impact of the pandemic and what do
you think will be the impact on the
pandemic the lockdowns and everything
else that we've done
in terms of income and wealth and
equality going forward
well it's made it worse i mean there's
no doubt about it there was a big piece
in the financial times which
uh you can you can probably get through
the paywall if you try hard enough
but essentially looking at how much
billionaires have made the billionaire
class the 0.1 percent
and it's astonishing i mean you'd expect
it would be you know the united states
etc and they're up there but it's the
swedish billionaire class which has made
tons
right it's the russians it's other
people there so it's a global phenomenon
it's not just the us and the uk by any
means
and here we call this the k-shaped
recovery right so if you think of the
letter k
if you're on the top end that's great
that means you have assets
we've pumped tons of cash into the
economy when you do programs like qe and
you're buying bonds you're swapping out
bonds for cash you're putting it in the
hands of people who already have
assets what do they do they go buy
assets you should see the housing market
over here just now
holy hell i mean you can literally put a
ship box with lipstick on the door
and you can sell it for a million bucks
in some places i mean it's ridiculous
why is that because everybody's dying
for houses well there's certainly pent
up demand
we didn't really do any housing starts
in 2020 because of covert
but a lot of it is just like the people
who have assets now have cash and want
to buy even more assets because
that's what goes up in value so a lot of
this also feeds into the
the inflation fee that we've got just
now is like look at the price of housing
that's going up that's not an inflation
that's a bunch of people who already
have everything buying even more stuff
pushing the prices up right it's a very
different thing but it's definitely made
it worse
this is again to go back to what biden's
trying to do and you can think about
sort of a weaker version of this at
least
vocally is the leveling up the country
discourse in the uk
is that it's going to be really hard to
take that top end where all the wealth
is concentrated
and redistributed down so what we need
to do is push the bottom up
so you you basically make the curve flat
right that's how you're going to do it
and that's basically you know the the
thinking on raising wages running the
economy hot etc
they realize they've got to do something
about inequality and the way they're
going to do is raise the bottom rather
than try and tax the top because the tax
won't let you the top won't let you do
it
and but mark isn't also the problem that
you raise wages at the bottom what covid
has allowed
a lot of companies to do is usher in
automation
via the back door very very easily
yeah and and some of those jobs should
be automated right i mean that's the
thing
are we really better off as a society or
even individuals if you have people
working for a couple of quid an hour
doing something that could be automated
wouldn't it be better for that person
not to do that you wipe out all those
jobs and effectively what you then have
is a higher wage floor
so then it's up to those people to get
the skills to get in to get on that wage
floor
and then the whole of the country is
working at a higher level so you know
a good example is there are no harm
there are no hand car washes in
scandinavia
none everything's automatic because
basically they just automated that whole
sector
why is that because basically they don't
want to have a low wage economy it's
like why
i mean this is the thing if you go and
go to denmark go to copenhagen
and go into a mcdonald's buy everybody
breakfast and then
[ __ ] your pants about how much it just
cost you right right
it's a fortune right and that's a policy
choice because basically you want your
wage flow to be high
and you want to have a certain type of
society and what we've been doing in
america in the uk is running a very
different one the low tax low wage one
and that's great for corporate profits
but it sucks for the people who have got
the low wages
and there's a question of you know have
we hit the buffers on that model
have we taken that as far as we possibly
can and yeah that's pretty much where we
are
but isn't that also if you try and
change that that's what america's built
on that's their ethos those are their
values
are you going to be able to do that is
that realistic
well it's a bit like you know it goes
back to the question of can you afford
this
and if you look back in time you go well
you used to pay more taxes why can't you
do it now
right it's not as if it's unprecedented
so
you know we talk about the the the biden
increase in corporate tax
if you follow it through on a graph
right gabriel zuckman put this on
on twitter here's the rate of corporate
tax it goes up to basically 50 odd
percent
and then it dives down to where it is
now at 21. and he basically wants to
take it to 28. and this is called an
unprecedented rise it's like no no
that's not unprecedented right
you've got lots of room and the simple
fact is that
particularly large corporates this is
not true of small businesses and this is
an issue right
but if you're talking about large
corporates they've never made more money
i mean apple's cash pile is bigger than
the gnp of around 40 countries
and they hide it in tax havens and pay
no attacks on it
and it's like no enough we're just not
going to do this [ __ ] anymore you guys
need to pay more to your workers that's
the deal
well and more more tax to the economy
for that would be nice as well mark
why do this is an issue that to me seems
very odd that we're even
having this conversation because it
seems to me like
the only way that the current system of
tax loopholes would exist
is if we had corrupt politics where the
people with the money
are paying off the politicians to keep
it that way
and we're all seven billion of us
sitting around just letting it happen
now given the fact that you guys are
domiciled in the uk
and i don't want to get done for libel
i'm not going to say what's in my head
right now
what i am going to say instead is that
yeah duh absolutely you know a great
example of this is that sort of like
um how can i put that the former prime
minister
formerly known as david cameron before
he became mr greensville
um when he in 2010 he did the so-called
edinburgh declaration which is you know
as part of our fiscal belt tightening
we're about to do
we're going to raise more taxes in the
era of tax dodging for companies over
blah blah blah
and what did they do they cut taxes and
loosened the tax codes
right i mean if you look at the maps of
global finance in terms of financial
flows london is this enormous hub
for money that comes from all over the
world and they get shipped out to a
series of tax havens and then those tax
havens actually serve as the
headquarters for companies but they have
no local tax rates so they have to pay
their
and yeah and like london is at the
absolute epicenter of this stuff
so the level of hypocrisy on taxation is
just
absolutely astonishing but again to go
back to your earlier point i mean this
shows you the power of the billionaire
class
right i mean why was lex green cell
right this basically billion
billionaire bullshitter able to get
access
to the phones of every member of the
government the mart
right i mean you know in any other
country you might be calling that
corruption yes so how does it work on
the political level if i am some
junior member of the prime minister's
staff and i'm like
hey prime minister we're going to solve
the corporate tax loopholes i run in
there with this great plan what happens
from there
well what tends to happen from there is
treasury comes in and says well it'd be
nice to have more money but i don't
think it's going to work and then
somebody from legals will come in and
say well in order to do that you're
going to have to violate the dominion
status of jersey
and you're going to have to change our
relationship with all these other crown
dependencies
and you don't want to get into that
because then what will happen is the
city of london which has its own
representative in parliament
not many people know this will then
start give it
yeah no the city of london has its own
representative in parliament who is not
elected
look it up it's amazing right and they
will basically lobby the crap out of us
and at the end of day 11 of gdp and 8
of all jobs is connected to the
financial center and given the fact that
basically the london housing market is
the world's largest money laundering
operation
um do we really want to screw this up
let's think it through how about a
commission we'll have a royal permission
to study yeah
and then five years from now when they
report i'll be gone you'll be gone
that's what happens i mean it's
it's so depressing because as well it's
not in their interest like you said and
everybody's playing the game
the eu's playing the game everybody's
out absolutely and this is why you can
never you know
i mean you're beginning to see this now
because what happens is i mean the
americans are still the elephant in the
room right and if the elephant shits in
the room everybody notices
so under the trump administration they
pulled out of the oecd
corporate tax harmonization stuff on the
grounds quite legit
that this is all aimed at our digital at
the digital firms
and it's right they pay no taxes and
that's an issue and all the rest of it
but the way this is structured they'll
be the only ones paying tax
and they're american firms so forget it
we're done right so they walked out
so then they came back and said all
right no taxing the digital
on their own everybody let's hit 28
and the french went holy [ __ ] are you
serious that could be awesome
so there's convergence between the eu
and the us and if you get the two of
them to agree
right then basically you've got it your
problem there is the latvians right
the problem there is uh who also the
dutch right
so all the people that benefit from
being kind of financial entrepreneurs
they're not going to like this one at
all and because you need unanimity in
the in the eu to do anything right it's
going to be tough to get that through
which is why they're doing it through a
different organization called the oecd
which makes it easier
but they are trying genuinely to get
there they understand that this is a
problem
and also what's interesting if you talk
to corporates in the us about this it's
kind of funny
some of them don't mind because
basically they're like yeah you're right
i mean basically we wake up as a firm we
make a billion dollars a minute right i
mean it's absurd
so why are we you know not taxed we
should actually be a bit more tax
another one you get is yeah i'm in favor
of taxation because a lot of firms are
just basically profitable because they
don't pay any tax
so if we actually all pay the same tax
you get to figure out who's basically a
[ __ ] or who's not
so the great reveal would be like oh
look at that we thought you were a firm
and it turns out you're just a tax dodge
so if you're actually an efficient firm
you could see this is gaining a
competitive advantage i actually make
sure you're just a tax dodger i'm going
to take your market share
so there's a way in which actually
having a higher bot equitable
tax base might benefit firms overall so
that's why there hasn't been the forming
at the mouth you would expect over this
topic
and and mark isn't another incentive the
fact that
a lot of well every country at the
moment is verging on being broke because
of covid
they need a fight to find a way to
generate more income
therefore you tax these huge
multinational digital corporations
yeah i'd put it slightly different um so
long as you're not an eu and you haven't
given up your printing press technically
you can't go broke
and the only real constraint is are you
having a large inflation
of which i mean double digit and it's
sustained which is a problem
or alternatively the the what you have
to pay an interest on your bonds goes
far higher than your growth rate
so as far as we can see it what you can
do is basically look at what's called
the yield curve right basically 10 years
out
what what's the interest rate likely to
be on these bonds and basically for
pretty much all the oecd
you've got a negative real rate out to
ten years like the germans are trading
at like negative six eight or something
like this
so essentially what that means is you
don't have a financing constraint it's
not you can't go bankrupt
now do they want the extra taxes yes
they do and they want the
extra taxes because they want to a stop
populism
by b raising wages by c
making people a bit happier about their
general condition in labor markets
so that they can restore faith in the
basic institutions around them
and d so that these elites don't
eventually end up getting hung drawn and
quarreled
right so that's basically the game plan
everywhere
mark uh can you explain something for
our viewers who may not be economist i
studied economics at university a little
bit but even i
kind of i understand the explanation but
i'm not sure whether i believe it
we we do have in the west
in many countries levels of debt that
are huge particularly for peace time
right the cycle used to be
you you spend money on wars then you
recover in peace time you build up
some reserves and then you spend them
all in another war right
whereas what we have is essentially
covered as like a war but we were
already
deeply in debt before it happened now
we've borrowed more money
but you're saying we can borrow more we
have to pay back less it's fine a lot of
economists talk about
mmt modern monetary theory again this is
to an ordinary person it sounds
absolutely [ __ ] crazy it sounds
bonkers right absolutely
and the key thing is is because anybody
who says to you well the economy is
about like a household is either an
ignorant person or a bullshitter because
an economy with its own printing press
is nothing like a household
right there is no such thing as kissing
dollars if there were
dollars i'd short the [ __ ] out of them
right they wouldn't last
very long right there's no such thing as
a mark blythe 10-year bond
because i'm scottish i might be dead
within 10 years right
so all of the things that states can do
bring people into the household they're
called immigrants
you can tax them over the generations
right all that sort of stuff
households can't do right it's just
simply not the same thing
so when they say that right well you
can't spend more than you earn it's like
well actually you can
because there are people out there in
the world called investors who are
willing to basically loan you money
because they want the security of
knowing that it's safe for up to 30
years
and because of that what you're
effectively doing with a bond is taking
your tax revenue none of this is mmt you
don't need to go near that this is
straightforward right
but you can you're essentially taking
the tax revenue you will have in the
future
and borrowing it from someone and then
with the tax revenue in the present
you're paying
out now what is then important how much
taxes you generate
and the interest rate on the debt as far
as we can see
just simply because of demographic
pressures the fact that interest rates
honestly have been falling
with the exception of the 70s and 80s
for 700 years by most estimates
straight down we're going to be in a
very low interest rate environment for a
while
it's also with zero wage pressures
unlikely that we will see a sustained
inflation
so you just don't have that problem
because a state is not a household
and so long as you have a global
investor class that wants to hold these
bonds as safe assets
the game just continues but if i'm an
ordinary person which i am
and i'm asking i'm hearing you explain
that i'm going well why don't we borrow
endlessly all the time to continually
invest in stuff and
buy buy everybody a porsche it sounds
great
well you'd have to buy everybody a
porsche but you could get them up to the
level where
let's say there's a recent study by rand
so if anybody wants to do this go on
go on online and look for rand
corporation rend
and i'll look for a paper called trends
in income 1979 to 2020
and what it shows is that if you haven't
changed any of the regulations in the
united states economy
or any of the tax rates in the united
states economy since 1979
your average worker would have been 15
000 a year better off
yeah so add that up over 40 years they
could buy their own porsche
right so there's a way in which we set
the means right when you change taxes
when you change regulations you're
benefiting one group over another and to
go back to your inequality point what's
happened is the corruption of politics
has essentially meant that it's all gone
to a tiny sliver of humanity
and the rest of us have been living on
crumbs so
debt is part of the equation but so are
wages so are taxes
and if you have a decent tax system and
a high growth rate say your growth
rate's here
interest rate in your bond is here it
literally doesn't matter because this
will shrink over time
take the example of wartime united
states comes out the second world war
164 percent debt to gdp
huge amount of ludicrous way for way
more than we've got now
and that's when it had the fastest and
uninterrupted period of growth
uh in its history and
after 30 years of that growth its debt
to gdp was down to 40 percent
so again the story that we tell each
other is a particular version of the
story which when you
figure out how this actually works it's
all financing
can you finance it or not an example you
live in london
let's say 10 years ago somebody said i'm
going to buy a house and crouch and
you're like well you're brave
all right so it's half a house in crouch
round how much is it
350 000 how much is your wages 50 000
[ __ ] seven times income i'm going to buy
it you're over levered you've got way
too much debt
10 years later how much is that house
worth about 10 million at the moment
right exactly right so therefore because
the economy
grew so much the amount of debt shrunk
in real terms
that's the analogy you need to think
about
it's it's really interesting that you
say that and also as well mark the
the point that the elites want to do
this in an effort to stop populism
but i'm looking at what's happening to
the eu you know the
the situation in france their abysmal
handling of the vaccine
isn't the cat already out of the bag
when it comes to populism
no it certainly is and if you think
about it this way the two largest
parties in italy
are basically the fratelli da talia who
are the ones who are like no no we
really are a fascist party we're not
hiding it
right then then there's la liga which is
kind of like well some people say we're
fascists but honestly we're kind of not
maybe we are and then you've got the
rump of berlusconi
which is a vision you didn't need in
your head which is forza italia and if
you put all of them together you can
have a government
right and that's that's the one where
investors go oh
[ __ ] right and then the italian debt
market's a problem all right so where is
let's think about go back to debt where
is that a problem
italy why is it really a problem the
whole thing is so long as your growth
rate's higher than the interest you pay
in your bonds you're fine
italy hasn't grown in over 20 years
and it's piled on a ton of debt since
the pandemic and because it's in the eu
it doesn't have its own printing press
so it can't do certain things like
basically stimulate the crap out of the
economy and hope for the best
so it then relies on the ecb buying its
bonds to keep the yields down keep these
interest rate payments down
but once the eu recovers whatever that
is
then they no longer buy those bonds and
at that point investors holding italian
debt go
no way are you guys going to grow enough
to generate the taxes to pay these bonds
so the interest rate's going to go up
and you could have another crisis at
that point in time that's when the
populists go
told ya and boom they're in right so
there is
real risk there that is baked into the
cake so much of it has to do with the
fact that when you join the euro
you give up your own printing press and
a lot you get some advantages from that
but whenever there's any kind of
turbulence bad idea
and you say it's a bad idea how close do
you think
the entire eu project is to failing
not as much as most british people hope
to be frank uh because you know and i've
used this analogy many times and i think
it still works it's the hotel california
won't you check in you can't check out
right if the italians were to go stuff
this we're out
enough of the euro we're gonna bring
back our own currency how would you do
it
you probably have a parallel currency
right and you would use that we'll call
it the new leader
and you would just put it in the atms
and you would have euros but you'd also
have these
and you could say these things you can't
use them in shops but you can use them
to pay your taxes
all right that's great that's 40 of my
income right there i can just take care
of that with this new currency
so when you're doing that you're
basically allowing it to spread people
start to go well if i could pay my taxes
with it i might as well buy groceries
with it right
and suddenly the euros like one of these
parallel things it's like a blatant
american economy
and at that point in time you've got to
wonder if this thing's going to work or
not
and there's a good chance that anybody
who's holding that's like do i really
want to hold new leader
or would i rather have a bank account in
germany with real euros
so any italian with money that doesn't
have rocks in their head basically opens
up a bank account in berlin
stuffs it full of euros that huge amount
of capital flying out of the country
would cause its own economic crisis and
in general the cost of getting out of
the euro
probably 50 percent of national savings
now you may be a fascist and you may be
a populist but you really want to
destroy half a national savings to prove
a point
mark one thing that goes somewhat
against the narrative that we were
discussing earlier which is
working people ordinary people the
bottom 60 percent if you like
really struggling uh not happy with the
system
20 are really struggling the bottom 60
are just pissed off
right right so the bottom 60 are pissed
off uh
what what they want is higher wages
they're purchasing power over god knows
how long has been
plummeting savings people really
struggle to put any money aside
etc etc etc but the one country that
bucks
the trend on that you might say is the
uk because we've voted
now basically the all the polling shows
that yeah ordinary people in this
country completely support
the right leaning party how do you
explain that
it is a fascinating one but i don't
actually think it's a this proof or a
contradiction
i mean if you had the tory party circa
1987
they wouldn't be talking about leveling
up right they wouldn't have done
furloughs they wouldn't be talking about
big investment projects greening the
account none of that would be on it'll
just be like tax cuts for us and screw
everybody else right
so it's a very different conservative
party and what they've done is they've
moved to the left economically and
stayed on the right culturally
and that is the winning combination and
the reason labor got slaughtered is
because if you are perceived to be a
party essentially of
elite intellectuals cities universities
and minorities
you're never going to get the white
working class to support you
and that's basically what's happened and
so long as the tories have moved to the
left whereby
their interests are being recognized
economically and then they want to stay
right culturally that is a winning
combination there's no way for labor out
of that box
i think matt goodwin has got this
absolutely right well we've had him on
the show a few times as
you probably know um but i'm curious and
what about
is that different in america in the
sense that the sort of progressive
coalition play we just need
basically for the country to get darker
and
you know more lgbt and more this and
more that
and we'll get to a point where that's
that is the winning formula is that
going to happen
so that's still the debate very much in
the democratic party and what you see
with biden and the whole attempt
to raise wages at the bottom is that's
not enough
right elections are increasingly won by
tiny tiny fractions
so when you see a result like you see in
hartlepool you sit up and go wow that is
that's a big thing that's structural
it's a lot of information in that
and if i was the biden team i'd be
looking at this and saying okay what
exactly is the conservative party the
conservative party with one or two
exceptions
is about as right-wing as mainstream
democrats at this point in time
they're way closer to the democrats than
they are to republicans so at that point
in time you know if that's the play why
wouldn't we do that play
now biden's not going to piss off his
activists he's not going to alienate his
base he's not going to do this
but he's not going to talk about trans
every day right he's not going to talk
about police violence every day
he's just going to keep silent on those
issues and concentrate on what he does
which seems to be stuff that people find
popular
so yeah there's definitely a sort of a
struggle in the democratic party
over basically how to use the word walk
the party wants to be and you've got
people like jim carville saying
this is a problem not because it's
ethically a problem or morally a problem
just politically you can't mobilize
enough people if you go down that road
and part of a part one way to look at
what's happened to labour is by going
significantly down that road they've
kind of tested that theory and shown
that it's probably true
and all these parties seem to be
struggling
with the effects of globalization what
can you do with these communities that
have had the heart and soul ripped out
of them
is are there any really any solutions to
this problem mark
well that's it to go back to the thing i
was saying earlier about cities right
once they start on a decline some of
them can bootstrap their way back and
reinvent themselves but not everywhere
can
right you've got to have a reason to
want to put capital into a place
you can move government jobs around you
can take the dvlc at a cardiff and stick
it somewhere else if you really want to
right
but there's getting private sector
capital in these places
depends upon making them actually much
better places to live
so if you think about a city like
manchester i would bet on manchester
also bet on liverpool huge investment in
the 1990s and improving if you are the
basic infrastructure of those cities
you get better transportation and
communication links there what have you
got
really good cheap housing you don't have
in the southeast right and the ability
to basically grow those economies out
and then you've got skilled labor forces
you've got good universities
that's a place where you could bet on
right what about your
bodies what about norwich right what
about places like that that basically
you know are on the skids the classic
one are sort of the coastal communities
south of london
on the east coast right it's not clear
what you do with that i mean once
skegness loses its appeal it's not
coming back
but it's not true everywhere so the
question is where do you put your money
and where do you maximize your bets to
try and balance things out a bit
but you're right one of the things about
globalization we don't talk about is
what it does is it creates the dominance
of cities
so there's a paper i'm working on just
now and i found these statistics and i
was absolutely fascinated by it
you know what percentage of gdp london
creates for the whole country
22. i was gonna say 20 yeah right now
here's one
paris what do you think it is for paris
vis-a-vis france
five no 30
what yeah right here's one
uh the netherlands amsterdam
30 wow right so and and then here's the
best one
dublin
yeah that makes sense to me right right
now
but what's actually happening is that
you get globally connected cities that
become the real wealth generators so
when we think about holland what you're
effectively talking about is amsterdam
right when you think about britain you
do really think about london right
that's it
and if you think about germany it's
actually very different because berlin
the hopscot is bust
bankrupt right for the from the
unification period
three lander in the south make most of
the money but it's not city based right
and there's much more kind of like you
know general redistribution because of
the federal system
um so you know globalization affects
countries in different ways but one of
the predominant ways it does is
basically by making these
global growth series like the main story
and you know when you've got that that's
a dynamic what do you want to do do you
want to not play that game
right there's going to be cost to doing
that mark i was going to ask you
we've talked about the fact that
different
people in society different strata of
society
have benefited and suffered differently
as a result of the pandemic
what about geopolitically one of the
things that people talk about
a lot is is china what will change and
what has already changed in terms of the
economic
power balance and also going forward
what will be the impact of the pandemic
in terms of
china the us and the rebalancing of of
power in the world
so it's an interesting one and my
bellwether for this is usually the eu
who like to play a game of hide
seek and take the money right so you
know they're about as principled as
robin hood's bad
cousin right so um and they signed this
big investment agreement with china but
it turns out the european parliament put
the whole thing on ice
they're just not going to play there are
genuine security concerns around
huawei 5g even if you don't have
substitute tech all this sort of stuff
so we're already seeing the beginnings
of what tech people call the splinternet
as it splinters into different national
versions of the internet
there's a really interesting investment
firm in one in new york actually that's
betting on this
and um they basically are looking for
you know who's going to be
who's going to be uh the deliveroo for
indonesia
because it's not going to be delivered
why would you need an american firm to
do this
right so you're going to see more and
more of this kind of like local national
or regional hubs in terms of that
in terms of the overall geopolitics of
it there is an increasing school of
thought that thinks that she has
overplayed his hand
the if he really does something like try
and grab all the semi-conductor
manufacturers for the world by invading
taiwan
then the cost of doing so would be very
very high for everyone but particularly
for china
because it would effectively turn
everybody else against them
so the belt and road stuff has been at
best a mixed bag a lot of it tends to
tends to basically indebt the people who
are borrowing
and then you end up owning the asset
which is good for china but not for the
other side
and then of course the whole sort of you
know the human rights data surveillance
surveillance society type stuff
which you know when you describe it
neutrally just doesn't sound like an
appealing place to be
if that's going to be the future maybe
you know maybe liberalism isn't dead
after all maybe it is worth fighting for
so i think at this point in time you
know conflict is baked into the cake but
what that how that conflict manifests
itself is going to be an interesting one
the last one on this and then i gotta go
run and pick up my kid
so i'm gonna have to go but anyway um is
how climate intersects in all of this
so so if the republicans come back in at
some point which they probably will then
america drops off the climate change
bandwagon again
the problem with this is the rest of the
world will eventually turn against
carbon assets
oil gas etc etc bank of england came out
today and basically said we've got a new
ratings regime next time there's a
crisis
if you want your bonds bought you'll get
a premium on them if you're not
carbon heavy and if you are carbon heavy
you'll have to pay attacks and we might
ultimately not buy your [ __ ]
whoa there's a big threat so you can see
all of this moving in one direction all
of that
speaks cooperation with china because if
they play this game they've declared net
zero by 2016. the communists don't
usually do plans or at least claim them
unless they're serious about them
so they're going to do this the eu's
going to do if the democrats control the
us they're going to do it if the
republicans come back and the rest of
the world's going to move that way
anyway
and all those carbon assets in 20 years
time are going to be worth a lot less
so you've got conflict on one side but
you really need to cooperate with them
on another
so it's going to be interesting how they
square that circle
it's good it's going to be very very
interesting would you say that china's
reputation
as a result of this mark has been
irreparably damaged
i don't know irreparably right because
ultimately
there are people for whom reputation
doesn't really matter
and there are countries for whom belt
and road is like the only source of
investment they're going to get and
they're simply not going to say anything
and there are plenty of dictatorships in
the world who are like your score what a
great model let's go that way
right think places like burma right
sorry my anmar
right but anyway um so yeah
unfortunately you know
that doesn't mean permanent
delegitimization nor does it mean that
they'll go oh we went too far
maybe we should come back this way a
little bit they have their own game plan
and as far as they're concerned it's
working for them
uh mark listen we got to let you run
otherwise we could chat to you for hours
as always we'll
love to have you back another time thank
you so much for coming on remind
everybody before you go where they can
find you online
you can find me at mkblyth on twitter
that's the easiest one
i have a website but i haven't updated
it since 1972.
fantastic thanks for coming on mark and
thank you all for watching we will see
you very soon
with another episode like this one or a
live stream and they always go out
7pm uk time take care and see you soon
guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to
subscribe and hit the bell button so
that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry
is important support us by joining our
locals community
using the link below